[Music]
[Music]
health educator former chief
nutritionist over at the dr.
McCullough's office optimal Wellness
Center yeah can I get you a coffee
huh no thank you
no but a freshly made organic vegetable
juice I'd be happy to take wine I think
about this so how about how about a pop
no thank you nothing else no fake food
for no faithful no only only real food
from how about some ah some water some
water yes that would be good
filtered tap yeah what would you prefer
if it was if it was properly filtered
and the fluoride and the chlorine and
any heavy metals and any other toxins
were properly filtered out of the water
I would certainly take that or I would
also take some glass bottled spring
water notice I emphasize glass bottled
spring water don't drink water out of
plastic bottles although that's very
common for people to do that in
modern-day America that's not the
healthiest way to consume water because
unfortunately the plastic from first
time use bottles the plastic some of the
plastic molecules will leach into the
water and plastic molecules are not
conducive to someone being in good
health
plastic is another toxic burden on the
body
plastic is known to be an endocrine
disruptor endocrine disruptor means it
messes with your hormones and it's very
common all too common in modern-day
America for people to have hormonal
problems hormonal imbalances thyroid
hormone problems the sex hormone
problems
problems with testosterone estrogen
progesterone so it's good to avoid
plastic as much as you can as far as
beverage containers and food containers
yeah well I got to be a good host and a
good take care of my guests I got it
what can I get you I think last time
before we didn't know we educated we
educated our viewers when I brought you
that cake huh but you just brought
you've been I mean God bless you you've
been so kind and you've been bring in
some some of these from from Adrian's
farm his brother yes yeah Myron Myron
plap now I know you wouldn't turn down a
nice raw egg no way not now they're not
from I'm not from a now some people
might not be happy check in not
commercial now right so this is tell us
you love about these eggs
well these eggs are from a true organic
farmer who is with the hold on a second
I would actually like to take my egg and
demonstrate the eating yes yes what I
call the warrior way yeah
the warrior way of doing raw egg
nutrition so this is a fresh raw egg
obviously and that cooks not it hasn't
been hard-boiled fresh raw egg from a
very healthy happy chicken I know these
chickens every time I go to get these
eggs is see them running around the
barnyard with all the cats and you
actually drive all the way to the farm
yeah yeah well all the way to the arm is
about 90 miles west of Chicago in a
farming community called Malta but I
know the the farmer I know his farming
practice I know who's raising practices
for his chicken and these are the the
finest eggs that I know of and when you
have truly high-quality fresh eggs from
from healthy chickens and you want to
get the most nutritional value out of
that egg consider consuming the egg
totally non heat damage that is totally
raw none heat damaged at all now there
is a place for cooking food but cooking
does damage and destroy nutrients to
some
extent there's still value in cooked
food as long as the food is not
overcooked but there can be more
nutritional value in the food that is
raw now in in recent years there has
been a lot of attention in our American
culture and in the field of nutrition in
regard to eating raw foods unfortunately
most of the book that address most of
the books that address the practice of
eating raw foods they limit the practice
of eating raw foods to just raw plant
foods raw vegetables raw fruits raw nuts
and seeds raw sprouted grains and
legumes
there certainly is value there but one
of the most important nutritional
lessons I've learned and so I teach this
is that the practice of eating raw foods
should also be extended to raw animal
foods not just limited to raw plant
foods this is something we had great
appreciation for in my years at the
optimal Wellness Center when because of
the popularity of dr. McCullough's
website we were certainly one of the
busiest nutrition based health centers
in the country teaching our patients how
to use food like their medicine to
strengthen themselves where they were
weak and balance themselves they were
they were out of balance and build their
health and realize freedom from all kind
of different medical conditions so our
approach was basically to teach people
how to build their health is the best
way to overcome any type of chronic
health problems a way I came to phrase
it that he has a bit of poetic vibe to
it is the best way to overcome what you
could call the darkness of disease is to
turn on the light of health build your
health so raw egg nutrition is something
I've recommended to thousands and
thousands of people over the years and
no one has ever gotten sick following my
guidelines on eating raw eggs because
most people think ok you get some
Salmonella or something
No not if the eggs if no one's ever got
to pick from no your oh and your watch
no one has ever gotten sick following my
guy and guidelines on eating raw egg
nutrition which the you know the basic
guideline is only do this from very high
quality fresh organically raised chicken
not a commercial or drugs right now you
know I don't I don't recommend eating
foods from the factory farms foods from
the conventional farming industry I
don't mind a little own raw ok nothing
wrong with because the most people I
mean I cooked eggs and you like to keep
it more runny like sunny-side up but
what you're saying is that you get more
bang for your buck because when you cook
it is that proven scientific that you
actually destroy most of the nutrients
well no no I'm not you're you're
damaging you're damaging damaging and
destroying a significant amount of
nutrients I'm not going to say most but
you're also changing you're changing the
the energy of the food you know this egg
and a fresh raw state it represents
potential life ok if this egg was was
sat on by it by a chicken or properly
incubated it would have to chicken if
you cook the egg will it hatch a chicken
no no because when you cook the egg you
kill the life-force energy value that's
in the egg you still get some
nutritional value still get some
calories to burn you get some some other
support of nutrients some vitamins and
minerals but if you cook an egg you kill
the life-force energy value the best
health building food has a lifeforce
energy value to it the fresher the food
is the higher the lifeforce energy value
and also when you eat the food in a non
heat damaged raw state there's also
going to be more potential lifeforce
energy value there so to get the maximum
positive not only nutritional benefits
but get that that lifeforce energy value
which is related to the nutritional
value but not entirely dependent on
just like we have a physical body and
when when someone dies the physical body
is still there but what is gone what is
gone is the life force energy of that of
that of that being of that of that body
so anyway let me demonstrate the warrior
way is I like to call it a filling a raw
egg you don't need a glass you don't
need a spoon you don't need anything you
just need your your teeth and so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to take the
tip of the egg and I'm going to crack it
on my canine - I've never seen this
before
hmm I've never done this for you okay so
see I got a I got a nice nice little
hole there in the tip of the egg green
outing now I'm going to I'm going to
suck the most of the white out of the
egg
[Laughter]
you call this the Warriors way huh when
you don't have all right the warrior way
the ultimate SAS food and great
nutrition fast food right yeah the holds
a subway this is the real fast this is
right this is the real the real fast
food that's greatly vary some valiant
the very nutritious arm but look at that
beautiful egg yolk in there you know Inc
of them thank you of that represents
potential life an egg a lay an egg
nutritionally is about 60 percent fat
calories all of the fat is in the yolk
and about 35 percent protein value
there's a small carbohydrate value to
eggs eggs are about 5% carbohydrate
value lots of vitamins and minerals and
enzymes in a raw state remember the
first nutrients you knock out of any
food when you cook it is the natural
enzymes that are in that food but anyway
so I've got this I've got this this
really good fresh raw nutrition and life
force energy value that I'm not going to
put into my body
all right why not give it a try huh all
right I've done it before
this is raw egg and at state again I
also eat the cooked eggs is now what I'm
say
you know don't cook them but why not try
raha let's you Smith hmm not bad not bad
little guys okay alright we've talked a
lot about eggs we got a lot more to talk
about here in the Dean show maybe health
educator Jim Marlo don't go anywhere
we're right back don't forget to Like
subscribe and share and do your best to
help us reach our goal more info in the
description below I sent out my alaikum
peace be with you
after you the pop you said no pop okay
and obviously I don't drink pop either
coke I heard by drinking just one coke
or one of these pops daily you increase
yourself your chance of diabetes by 30%
so you actually like bringing harm upon
yourself but here but this is a very
nutritious
if someone doesn't want to step up to
this like you said they can what do you
prefer if they cook it run it sunny-side
up
yeah well the less you cook the egg the
better yeah the less you cook the egg
and it's very weak someone can someone
is this is this a controversial tie is
this open for debate or are there
studies I mean most people they don't
look into this stuff I didn't either you
know and but now we trust people like
yourself who have dedicated their life
your your study studying this in this
area for I think around almost 40 years
you've dedicated your time your life
while other people are dedicated to
being experts in other fields you have
dedicated your life to be an expert in
this field so you've really done your
homework all right
yes I have yeah you have so we wouldn't
have you on the show if you have it tell
us um is there is is there is there
science behind us is there anything
where people wanted to research look
more into it they can go in and now I I
personally when I've looked at I've seen
a lot of tremendous of athletes I've
seen many bodybuilders many people Rocky
Balboa was drinking on this back bed
member in the movie Rocky and most of us
we just kind of you know not in tune
with this but I've taken the advice of
re-educating my taste buds and I really
want to take care of the blessing that
the Creator has given me this vehicle
that gets me through life and I have
felt the benefits I wanted to share this
with others again not taking people way
from from cooking anything but this is
another means that's touch out there
that I think is very beneficial it's
very convenient also and so what do you
have to say well you mentioned science
well you have the science behind us well
you know the most underappreciated part
of what science is is simply knowledge
gained from experience there's a
fundamental definition of what science
is I think a lot of people have been
misled to believe that sign
ances is mostly people in white lab
coats doing experiments and you know
with test tubes and petri dishes and
that's part of science too but anytime
you're learning from your own experience
you're gauging you're engaging in the
basic scientific method we're all
scientists to some extent if you're
learning from your life experience
you're you're basically you're engaging
in the basis of what science really is
knowledge gained from experience so all
over the world there are what I think
are appropriately called nourishing
traditions for people consuming raw egg
nutrition there's especially a lot of
appreciation for the value of giving raw
egg nutrition to children to support
healthy growth and development you know
nutrition is important for everybody
throughout our entire lives but
nutrition actually has its biggest
impact on the body when the body is
still growing and developing
so there are nourishing traditions and
all cultures around the world for giving
consuming raw egg nutrition giving it to
children sometimes they do it mixed with
sugar or honey which is not ideal but if
that helps to get the raw egg nutrition
into a child that has its place in
America raw egg nutrition unfortunately
is only relatively common and and
appreciated in the field of athletes
engaged in serious and often intense
training well let the caliber athletes
or boxers you mentioned the classic
scene from the the original Rocky movie
1976 where now this is a movie of course
but you know Stallone was was was he had
familiarity with body
building culture and boxing culture and
that's where he got that from to crack
like six or eight eggs and a glass and
chugged that down
that was really the initiation of him
starting his training in earnest to get
that nutrition into his body to build
yourself up you need to nourish yourself
properly you know exercise is very
important but your nutritional fitness
level actually makes a big impact on the
progress you make with your physical
training and your exercise the better
the better your nutrition the better
you're going to build muscle burn fat
enhance your energy your stamina your
ability to recover from an intense
workout tell us a little bit about
there's a there's many different Namie
some diets out there some are fad diets
they come and go some of the popular
ones that we hear about and then we can
touch upon what you feel and your in
your opinion is primary the best one
you've heard of the tell us a little bit
if people haven't heard about it kind of
a condensed version I'll name a few of
them and then you tell me what they're
about let's start off with a paleo diet
have you heard of this Paleo diet shirt
yeah the Paleo diet has been gaining in
popularity over the last 20 years the
Paleo diet is a diet where you try to
emulate what Paleolithic man was eating
what Paleolithic man was the people
Paleolithic women - Paleolithic men and
women they this is what people were
eating before the advent of Agriculture
before the cultivation of grains and
legumes and before the domestication of
animals to get dairy products and so the
Paleo diet is based on eating on eating
meats and fish seafood seafood being
every anything anything from the ocean
that is not a fish like shrimp and
lobster and so forth and then also eggs
and then lots of plant foods lots of
vegetables fruits in season
since seeds that sounds like real food I
mean it seems like oh yes a lot as the
concept you talk about yeah those of you
I never heard you mentioned
paleo dine ever heard you ever mention
much that this is the Paleo diet well it
just seems you just talked about eating
real food what the Creator has given us
see what God Almighty is given right
well that's that's a starting point to
always if you want to get your nutrition
right always start with giving faithful
attention to the quality of food that
you're eating and doing this you know
I've shared with you in the very first
time of zonda Dean show getting a
nutrition right begins with this with
having appreciation for this if you want
to be real healthy then eat real food in
real food is simple food that does not
come with a label with a list of
ingredients yeah okay we'll take a break
and we will come back with more we just
touched upon one and I would just in a
short amount of time I want to touch
upon maybe a couple more and then get
your opinion on what would be the best
diet you know to start off with and end
off with we right back with more don't
waiting working don't forget to Like
subscribe and share and do your best to
help us reach our goal more info in the
description below i said i'm alaikum
peace be with you
back here into Dean show with health
educator Jim Marlowe you got a lot of
experience you have an expansive amount
of knowledge in this area we've done
some programs in the past we touched
upon right now the Paleo diet
what about Atkins diet well the Atkins
diet is a low carb diet where you
actually get most of your calories from
high quality ideally very importantly
high quality animal protein and animal
fat like the Atkins diet like the Paleo
diet does not include grains really not
legumes either and really not much in
the way of fruits there's many different
versions of the Atkins diet depending on
whether or not you're implementing back
Ekans diet for very aggressive weight
loss or whether you're doing the Atkins
I more in a maintenance phase but the
Atkins diet is basically it's a it's a
lower carbohydrate diet where you're
getting most of your calories from
animal protein and animal fat and the
best plant foods for someone on the
Ekans I are very low in low carb
vegetables such as celery and spinach
and asparagus and string beans and and
and cauliflower and although they're not
formally vegetables we can consider
mushrooms a very low carb vegetable for
practical reason but you have you have a
ton I mean you have here on health.com
you have for instance daily whatnot wait
I don't know what website you're looking
at but I don't I don't have my own way
I'm like well these are just some of the
popular diets that are out there there
I've never heard of most of these - diet
mine diet TLC diet Weight Watchers at IO
clinic leave veggie die Jenny Craig diet
the Amish Ornish diet vegetarian diet
slimfast diet fat Flat Belly Diet this
diet dad die zombies diet and the list
goes on there are a lot of different
diets so how does someone pick the right
diet for themselves well what do we mean
when we say diet what does that
me that's what you're eating winking
what you're eating Andrea so how do you
how do you pick what is it what is the
right one from all of these how do you
act the right one well you need to have
some understanding first of all that in
our very diverse population of people on
this planet there is a spectrum of
possibilities for all things human
including the way we metabolize what we
eat and one of the reasons why there are
so many different diets in the
marketplace is because each one of those
diets is actually addressing what is
going to be at least generally right for
people who have different kinds of
metabolism so one of the ways that I've
been able to really help people get
their nutrition right over the years is
to help them understand how to eat more
in harmony with their metabolism how do
you identify what's going on with your
metabolism well it has to do with for me
from my perspective as someone who does
nutrition and health counseling knowing
the right questions to ask someone but
also bringing bringing to someone's
awareness about how they're really being
affected by by various foods that
they're eating and also learning from
them what are the most dominant
characteristics of what I call a
person's food personality so you
mentioned the Paleo diet and you
mentioned the Atkins diet and I think
it's important to mention that the
dominant dietary Dogma in America for
the last thirty plus years is that
everybody should be eating a low-fat
plant-based diet that's been the
dominant dietary dogma you also
mentioned the orange diet the Ornish
diet certainly is a prime example of a
low-fat plant-based diet Dean Ornish
promotes a actually a vegan diet and a
low-fat vegan diet where you're getting
all of your nutrition from from
vegetables and
and fruits and grains and legumes but
not really much in the way of or any in
the way of nuts and seeds or very little
of that and Dean Ornish writes books
about his successes and Robert Atkins
wrote books about his successes and the
the advocates for the Paleo diet they
write books about about people who are
successful doing that and what this if
you if you look at the big picture
rather than thinking you know what diet
you know what diet is is best of those
three they all have their value for some
people but there is no one diet that is
right for everybody it's not a
one-size-fits-all no of course not
everyone everybody everybody knows that
just from their own experience everybody
you've had enough life experience you've
known somebody who did really well with
a particular type of diet but maybe you
tried the same diet and it didn't work
so well for you or you know other people
that tried the diet of someone you know
that was doing well but it doesn't there
is no one diet that well how do you
figure out that from all of them which
one is best for you I like the concept
how you made it very simple eat real
food
avoid fake food that's a great starting
point right and and that's that's a food
quality issue that is fundamental to
everybody no matter what's going on with
your metabolism but as far as whether
you should be eating more vegetarian or
low-fat plant-based diet like like the
orange diet or many other diets that
that are similar to that or whether you
should be doing something very different
from that doing more of a low carb high
animal food intake diet like the eken
side or whether you should be doing the
Paleo diet and there's different
versions of the Paleo diet or whether
you should be doing like a Mediterranean
diet which is kind of a more of a
balanced approach with you where animal
food nutrition including fish and plant
food nutria
is considered to be of equal value it
has to do with what's going on with your
metabolism at this time in your life and
there are ways of identifying how do you
figure that out yeah well the first
thing to do is think about all of the
different real food groups as I divide
them that that would be meats as
specifically red meats in organ meats
and poultry and not also fish in seafood
and eggs and dairy products and
vegetables and fruits and nuts and seeds
and grains and legumes and sometimes
it's it's it's pretty obvious to people
what the dominant characteristics are
the food personality for instance
someone who has what I call carbo
metabolism is other carbon metabolism
side of what I call the spectrum of
possibilities for human metabolism
someone who's really in carbon
metabolism will naturally gravitate
toward toward eating salads and if they
have the opportunity to drink fresh
organic vegetable juice that will feel
good to them or if they drink orange
juice orange juice especially freshly
squeezed organic orange juice that will
feel good to them it'll be good for
their energy you know it'll help to
satisfy their hunger their appetite to
some extent
I'm not saying always completely but
someone who naturally gravitates toward
eating vegetarian and that helps them to
experience the best of health you always
have to you always have to consider your
your state of health in relation to what
you're eating if you're if you're eating
vegetarian but you're not doing well
consider that that maybe you've taken on
somebody else's belief about what you
should be eating and you're you're
you're you're forcing a vegetarian diet
on yourself but maybe a vegetarian diet
is not really right for you so it's it's
it's your level of health in relation to
what you're eating and when you're when
you're truly getting your nutrition
right you'll feel completely satisfied
with what you're eating you'll be moving
toward freedom from Crais
things you'll have more consistently
good energy mood and mental clarity
you'll have a sense that yes this is
right for me if you're listening to your
body rather than working with what I
call dietary dogma but if someone's on
what I call the protein fat metabolism
sides of spectrum someone who has a
biology that actually needs to follow
more of an Atkins type diet they're
going to gravitate toward eating meat of
some kind on a regular basis and when I
say regular basis usually they're going
to need some meat every day some people
actually have a biological need to eat
meat several times a day and someone who
has a metabolism that really thrives on
more of an Atkins type diet they're
going to they have to be very careful
with their carbohydrate intake very easy
for someone in what I call protein fat
metabolism to over consume carbohydrates
we're gonna have to curtail it we're
almost we're about out of time I'd like
to I mean this is a good topic to go
ahead and expand on because there's a
lot more to cover here what's a lot more
a lot more to cover someone wants to get
in touch with you some resources some
personal counseling sessions how as I
work well currently um actually even
busier than I want to be you're all
booked up yeah but I do know a wonderful
nutritionist who's actually been a guest
on the Dean show in the past her name is
Michele Gillespie you guys got there one
time yeah that's right and she has a
really nice website unlike me I've never
been interested in having my own website
but her website is Michele Gillespie
nutrition calm and got some great
information there I do believe she is
available to do phone consultations
phone consultations and also to do Skype
consultations I think she's connected to
do that she set up to do that I should
say and so if someone's looking for more
personal guidance
I think you're you would great resource
yeah you would you would get very good
guidance from from Michele Gillespie
thank you very much we gained a lot here
nice example of the warrior the warrior
way of going away on the egg check out
so many benefits out there do some
research stay away from fluoride in the
water oh yeah filtered water we talked
about that and then there's no one size
that fits all but that's all in the
context through real food in this fake
process you know things have gone
through all the additives of chemicals
is destroying destroying people real
food or someone real food yeah real food
is simple food that does not come with a
label with a list of ingredients and the
fresher your realtor it is the better
yes that's what we've been blessed with
and we've got this vehicle as gives us
through life let's take care of it
let's honor it by putting in what the
Creator has blessed us with of real food
thank you very much we'll see you next
time thank you Jim you're welcome HB may
give you honey don't forget to Like
subscribe and share and do your best to
help us reach our goal more info in the
description below assalamu alaikum peace
be with you
Oh